Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Hope that you have had a really lovely Easter break if you are listening to it as this episode drops at 6am on Monday. So today is episode 70 of the podcast, which feels like kind of a big deal. And it means I've stayed really, really consistent, which I'm really pleased about. And I've sent an email to my mailing list every week to tell them about the podcast. So if you're not already on the mailing list and you want to be reminded when new episodes drop, if you're not already subscribing, but even if you are already subscribing, sometimes, you know, life gets in the way and we forget to listen to our favorite podcasts. So yeah, why not sign up to my podcast mailing list, which you can do by going to my website, www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk. And then if
you scroll to the bottom of that first page, or that matter, any page on the site, you will see a little thing that says subscribe to mailing list. And if you are listening on Spotify or Apple podcasts, I love it if you would take a moment to rate and review if you're watching me on YouTube hi please do subscribe and like this video as it helps us to reach more of a wider audience so today was originally scheduled to be one of the podcast episodes that I've already recorded but haven't quite finished editing and yeah I've had a week off and always it was my plan to tidy those up but instead I actually did just have a week off because you're allowed to do that um and so yeah I found myself with an episode that wasn't ready and so I thought I'd just create a very short one um to yeah to encourage you to use your time off as time off as well. And to just pay reference to where you might be at right now. Because if you are having interviews for whatever realm of psychology
you're going into, I'm aware that there is a bit of hiatus at the moment a bit of a break over the Easter break probably to let the staff who are running the interviews have their Easter time off as well but it means that if you were in the in your stride really with interviews you might now be feeling a bit like what do I do now how do I maintain this you know um there's no energy going on you know now I'm just supposed to sit here and you know look at easter eggs and be cheery and suddenly have time for my family when actually what I want to do is you know submerge myself in um research theory and uh clinical vignettes you know it can be tricky to straddle the two so I'm sending you love if that's what you're finding to be the case um and also um someone made my day the other day um I was just going to bed and I checked my
LinkedIn because I'm very badly behaved like that and I saw that someone had sent me a lovely message I wanted to share that with you so there there's an intro, but I won't read that bit, but I'll cut to the chase. I wanted you to know that I'm a big fan of your podcast, not just the jingles, but the content as well. My colleagues introduced me to it and I've been listening ever since. I'm really interested to know how psychologists conduct themselves when in the therapy room, whatever that means these days. I'm particularly interested in reflexivity and I've gained a lot by listening to how you talk to your clients, the sort of questions you ask, the things you might pick up on and how you generally carry yourself. I suppose in that sense you're sort of role model
to me. I wanted to reach out and tell you that you've helped me in my journey, as I've today found out that I've been offered a place on the counselling doctorate at UWE, starting this September. So thank you for doing what you do. It's genuinely been a massive help. I even mentioned you on my personal statement as someone I model myself on, whilst also bringing my authentic self to. Thanks so much for being such a positive influence. Super grateful. Wishing you all the best. Honestly, when I read that, it almost brought me to tears because the idea that what I'm doing is making a difference is incredible.
Honestly, when I read that, that just made my day. You know, I created this podcast because I wanted to be able to level the playing field, to be able to give people access to thoughts, insights, reflections of a qualified psychologist, if you are not in that position where you have ready access to one or if you are but would welcome alternate perspectives or maybe you don't even like the person that's supervising you or those around you in your team and yeah I wanted to be able to have you guys advance your skills theory practice practice reflections and knowledge um you know but not be held up by those that you find yourself around you know because we're all busy people we absolutely are not everyone has got the time to spend with aspiring psychologists um you know ideally it would all be job planned and it would be happening regularly but even with the best of will in the world, that's not always the case. So that's part of the reason why I put this podcast together and why I'm remaining consistent with that. So I'm thrilled, you know, when people contact me just to say how valued it is, really.
And that's why reviews mean a great deal as well. So, yeah, if you do have a moment to drop me a review or if you'd like to leave me an audio testimonial for the podcast about the podcast itself or about the books the clinical psychologist collective or the aspiring psychologist collective or the grief collective for that matter you can do so very easily very simply by going to my website, www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast. And there's very quick click button on there that will take you to the platform that I use for recording testimonials. So honestly, that is about it for me for today. I hope you've, yeah, you can give me permission to give you a short episode today because everybody, even those working in mental health, especially those working in mental health, deserve and need time off.
Very likely you too. So you can give yourself permission to not work on the days where you're not working. You can give yourself permission to only work within the hours where you are working and where you're paid to work. If there's a culture whereby you work extra, it's okay to actually question and challenge that culture. It's okay to leave at your agreed finish time and only start at your agreed start time it's absolutely okay um and you know it's okay to be flexy as well if you need to be um discuss that with your management team and your supervisor if you need that at any given point you're not necessarily saying you need it forever
but you might be saying you need it right now and you know you're a human and we don't want you to burn out. And so time off and working in a way that helps you maintain your best for yourself and your clients is really important. So don't be afraid to ask those questions about whether there's any way that things could be done differently while still doing your job. The answer might be no. There might be good logistical managerial reasons for that. But it's OK to ask those questions.'t even help myself there could I have said I was going and then I chucked in a little learning point but do remember that we've got more compassionate Q&A dates coming up and next one is on Monday the 17th of April 2023 at 7 30 p.m and the one after that is on Tuesday the 2nd of May at 7.30pm and they'll be live streamed across my socials. So yeah if you've got any questions in advance let me know otherwise do tune in live and feel free to ask any questions there or just give me a high and a high five
that's fine too. The replay for the first one is also available via my YouTube, Dr. Marianne Trent. People are finding the Clinical Psychologist Collective and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective really useful reads as they prepare for interviews. So you might well find that useful, too. Hope, as I said, you've had a lovely Easter and I will look forward to catching up with you very soon from Monday at 6am for the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Until then, thanks for being part of my world and do stay kind to yourselves. Take care. health professionals on their way to getting qualified. So many tips and lessons to learn from. So many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective.
The Aspiring Psychologist Collective guys with this podcast that you'll find you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.